But before we get started, how do we
go about building our web application?
For many people, the most natural way
of going about a project is to just
dive into it head first, writing as much
code as possible before falling asleep.
While this method feels fast,
many times we end up spending more
time fixing bugs and examining code than
actually developing our application.
Another option is to code in pieces,
working on one page here,
another feature there, and
putting everything together at the end.
While this approach is a little more
organized, we may stumble across
several bugs when it's time to
integrate all of our code together.
Also, we won't have a working
prototype until we're finished with
the entire project.
But what if we took another approach,
starting out really simple and
layering on complexity as we go?
Not adding a new feature until
we finish the one before.
With each feature, we stop, test, debug,
and share to make sure we always have
a working application even if it's
very basic in the initial stages.
This way, anyone involved in
the creation of our product, such as
clients, managers, and team members,
always know what the project status is,
and what enhancements
are soon to follow.
This process is called
iterative development.
Iterative development allows
developers to code in an agile way.
What agile means is that since there
is always a working prototype,
if a client or teammate asks for
changes, as a developer,
you can react to that feedback quickly
without tripping up the entire process.
In this last lesson, you will plan,
organize, and execute development
iteratively to create a final
polished restaurant menu application